قال حسين امير عبد الله هيان وزير
الخارجيه الايراني ان الحل في غزه هو وقف
الحرب ووقف التهجير القسري وفتح الممرات
الانسانيه واضاف خلال جلسه نقاشيه ضمن
المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في دافس انه
اذا توقفت الحرب فستسقط حكومه نتنياهو بعد
عشر دقائق وقال عبد الله هيان ان امن
البحر الاحمر مرتبط بما يحدث في غزه وان
لم يتوقف ما يحدث بغزه فكل الاطراف خاسره
واشار الى ان الولايات المتحده ارتكبت
خطائين استراتيجيين من خلال دعمها
لاسرائيل وضرب الحوثيين وبشان استهداف
العراق وباكستان قال عبد الله هيان ان ما
قامت به طهران ضد ما سماه قاعده المساد في
كردستان وجيش العدل في باكستان لا علاقه
له بالوضع في غزه مضيفا ان ايران تحترم
سياده باكستان والعراق وسلامه اراضيه ما
لكنها لا تسمح بتهديد امنها
القومي